it's rarely consolation to say this but
things could certainly be worse
luckily netflix has got plenty of solid
options available if you want to watch
people banding together to survive
after the world has fallen to pieces
we start our list with bird box a
netflix film based on the novel of the
same name by josh malaran
it shows some of the world before
civilization fell but the movie mostly
takes place after a vast majority of the
world's population has died out
monsters have invaded our world monsters
that drive people insane if they catch
even a glimpse of them
the last few survivors live in homes
with blacked out windows
strapping blindfolds on whenever they
need to venture out for supplies
the movie stars sandra bullock sarah
paulson
trevontae rhodes and john malkovich and
features some really intense
scenes and fun set pieces there are some
logical leaps
but bird box is a darn entertaining rom
especially considering that it deals
with such dreary subject matter
i'm not cleaning this [ __ ] up is there
any other joel edgerton
as good as tragically downbeat joel
edgerton
it comes at night relishes in putting
the veteran actor through the ringer and
the film does a great job of making you
question what is really going on
and who you can actually trust it makes
the most of its tiny cast and minimalist
setting
and allows the viewer's imagination to
run wild and fill in the scariest blanks
it comes at night focuses on a family of
three paul
sarah and travis living in a remote
cabin a horrible and extremely
contagious
illness has wiped out much of the world
population and the family has a strict
set of rules to avoid contact with the
infected and to remain alive
unfortunately their strict rules are
overturned when another family stumbles
across the cabin and asks for their help
edgerton is great as paul and the rest
of the cast has some heavy lifting to do
to keep detention high and it comes at
night
this is one of those films where you
just know everything is going to go
wrong
and anticipation of the hammered
dropping is almost as thrilling as when
it all goes sideways
so it's just your wife and your son and
nobody else
just them how it ends probably qualifies
more as a disaster movie than a
post-apocalyptic one but it ticks a lot
of the same boxes
this netflix original is something of a
grounded more real world type of mad max
as the movie at its core is essentially
a road trip through a ruined earth
it's a post-apocalyptic buddy road trip
with forest whitaker and the guy from
divergent
what more could you want how it ends
follows a man named will
played by theo james who sets out on a
cross-country road trip to rescue the
woman he loves
after a series of cataclysmic events he
teams up with tom his girlfriend's dad
and the duo try to make it from chicago
to seattle
blocking their path is a host of outlaws
and panicked people
trying to make sense of what has
happened to the world
north korea isn't the chinese
who else could do this post-apocalyptic
movies may be a dime a dozen in the
united states but they're a rarer breed
in middle eastern cinema
in fact the worthy attracted a lot of
attention upon its release for this very
reason
it does an awful lot with a relatively
small budget and it's a good way to get
a fresh perspective on a well-trodden
genre
in the worthy the world's water supply
has been almost entirely contaminated
killing most of the population
it was poisoned by a political group to
silence their enemies but things got out
of hand
and nearly everyone died because of it
the plot centers on a small group of
survivors who have found a clean source
of water in an abandoned factory
as word gets out that the group has
access to clean water all sorts of
raiders come knocking
the worthy deals with themes similar to
many post-apocalyptic films
but seeing it from the perspective of a
culture that rarely touches the genre is
fascinating
go in open-minded and we think you'll
find a lot to like
snow piercer has got a lot of good going
for it there's the phenomenal cast
headed up by names like chris evans ed
harris tilda swinton
john hurt octavius spencer and
parasite's kang hosang
speaking of parasite snow piercer is
director bung jun ho's first
ever english language film it's also
extremely slick
based on the classic french graphic
novel that's a lot to like right there
snow piercer is dense and determined to
get its audience thinking
like parasite it deals in symbols of the
class structure and social constructs of
our own world
the basic premise is this the world has
entered another ice age
and the last remnants of humanity are on
a massive train that continually travels
the globe
the train is segregated by class the
rich are in the lavish front cars
while poorer residents are pushed
towards the back eventually a few of the
people in the back of the train lead a
revolt
and their push towards the engine sets
off some wild revelations
like many of bong joon ho's films snow
piercer gets absolutely bonkers by the
end
check it out still cold
cargo is a fascinating beast it's a
zombie movie but the zombies don't play
a big part in the overall proceedings
it's a fairly low budget affair
featuring several unknown actors and two
first-time directors
on the other hand the project is
anchored by a lead performance from
bilbo baggins himself
martin freeman it's an australian film
about the end of the world and just what
people can do to survive as everything
comes crashing down
cargo focuses on a couple and their
young child who live on a houseboat off
the coast of mainland australia
the rest of the country has been overrun
by a virus that transforms its victims
into zombies
so andy and kay only venture off the
boat when they need supplies
when something goes wrong on one of
their expeditions it becomes a race
against
time as they try to find somewhere safe
for their baby to have a chance
cargo is based on the director's
previous short film of the same name
and freeman and company bring deeply
emotional performances to the table
it's a brutal but ultimately uplifting
watch
[Music]
into the forest is a movie that was
destined to sink or swim on its two lead
performances
there are other actors in it but the two
sisters at the film center are the
driving forces behind nearly every scene
luckily they're two of the best actors
in the business ellen page and evan
rachel wood
each delivering dynamic performances in
this creepy and thoughtful into the
world film
without giving too much away here's the
basic premise wood and paige play eva
and nell two sisters who live in a
remote cabin with their father
a widower named robert played by calum
keith rennie they aren't totally off the
grid
however until the power goes out and
doesn't come back on
soon they start hearing rumors that
power is out for the entire country
and possibly the world there's a lot of
mystery in into the forest
but it's a movie that's less concerned
with what has happened than it is with
characters responding to it
it's quiet thoughtful and anchored by
two power house performances
give it a go if you want something a
little different from your standard
post-apocalyptic fare
you're forgiven if you didn't realize
mad max fury road was
actually the fourth film in a series
after all the franchise had been dormant
for 30 years when fury road was released
in 2015.
if you want to go all the way back to
the franchise's roots take a look at the
original mad max on netflix
released in 1979 mad max long held the
record for most profitable film
ever it reportedly cost under four
hundred thousand dollars to make
and took in 100 million dollars
internationally
not bad for a little australian film mad
max
like the other films in the series is
the brainchild of director george miller
he imagined a dystopian world where oil
had become the primary resource
and this original film tells how the
remnants of society coped with that
development
it may lack the sheen of fury road but
it still features plenty of
depth-defying driving and insane stunt
work
fury roadstar tom hardy would have been
only two years old at the time of this
first outing
the title character here and in the next
two films is played by the then unknown
and practically unrecognizable mel
gibson
don't miss this one you want me max
we're gonna give her back the heroes
[Music]
you really expect me to go for that crap
the girl with all the gifts is
essentially a zombie movie but it has
enough
elements of more traditional
post-apocalyptic stories that it's worth
a go
even if you think you're all zombied out
based on the 2014 novel of the same name
it features an impressive cast of
relatively unknown actors trying to cope
with a society
ravaged by a horrible disease there are
more than a few similarities between
this film and other apocalyptic kits
notably it holds a lot in common with 28
days later
and the video game the last of us the
girl with all the gifts is about a
fungal infection that turns humans into
hungries
where the twist comes in is with the
second generation hungries
children who had infected mothers these
hybrids crave human flesh but can still
think and reason
and are seen as a potential source of a
cure as such
they're raised in a school under tight
military guards so they can be studied
the girl with all the gifts has some
pretty impressive sequences
and the lead actress senya naniwa does a
terrific job of keeping you both
sympathetic and terrified
they're mine you can't have them
i am mother is one of those movies that
plays with cliches in order to subvert
your expectations
every time you think you've figured
things out another wrinkle is thrown in
to make you question everything you know
by the end of the film you'll be
questioning what you've seen wondering
if it's following the pattern of similar
films
or just making you believe it is the
film is about a young girl named
daughter who is raised by robots in a
bunker
her caretaker a robot named mother tells
her that humanity has been destroyed and
the world contaminated
their purpose in the bunker is to raise
enough humans to repopulate the world
all that is thrown into question when a
woman comes knocking on the door of the
bunker
and informs daughter that she's being
lied to a big part of
im mother's success comes from its tiny
ensemble of talented performers
the always impressive hillary swank
plays the woman who comes to the bunker
newcomer clara rugard plays daughter and
commands a lot of screen time
luke honker does the motion capture for
mother and rose byrne
voices her with chilling detachment
surface contamination levels remain
hazardous to you
and to all the unborns who one day call
this their home
if you'd like some stylish animation
with your post apocalypse you should
give blam
a shot it's a netflix produced film
based on the manga of the same name
and you should know that it's pronounced
blam not blame it gives off some of the
same vibes as terminator in the matrix
in the best ways the story goes like
this the ai system that humanity has
used to reach its zenith has gone rogue
and has started replicating itself and
exterminating humanity
a few small groups of survivors exist
many of them are just trying to eek out
in existence
but a few are actively trying to fight
back against the technology that is
hunting them
the action centers on a man named keely
who may just be the weapon humanity
needs to retake the world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you